all right mama you did it it's over now
we have loved your season I will say my
favorite season of The Bachelorette ever
and we kind of been on the journey with
you and I got to ask you I brought this
up to you before you did tell me at your
photo shoot that you did not want to end
up with a quote lying sack of poo did
your worst fear come true I don't know
do you think do you think Jed was a
lying sack of poo I do think that he
lied and I think that there was not the
foundation of trust and honesty that I
also have preached that I wanted I think
that there's he had some good qualities
and will learn a lot from this look
you're the Beast we know you're the
beast you've been the Beast the whole
time and you've asked for honesty the
whole time what was the breaking point
what made you finally end it with Jed I
think after that people article came out
it was really hard for me to see myself
with my head up high after this and I
wanted to be able to really take all
that I've learned from being a part of
the bachelor and the Bachelorette and be
the strong woman who knows what she's
worth doesn't settle and to be able to
do that I needed to be on my own and
that wasn't a relationship that I ever
wanted to be a part of it's not what I
thought I was getting you mentioned
other girls at his house he said he
wasn't faithful seemingly to the last
woman he was with do you think he
cheated on you I don't think he cheated
on me no I think he made some poor
decisions of you know when you're in a
serious you're engaged and it's
something so public you have to really
be careful about who you allow in your
life and protecting that relationship
and I don't think he always protected
their relationship do you think he
really wanted to get married I can't
speak for Jed but I know that he did
love me I think he probably wasn't ready
for an engagement when you come in with
understanding what this is but I do
think that he was falling in love with
me and fell in love with me and just
didn't MIT made the selfish choices and
didn't realize really what this snowball
effect would be I thought you handled
yourself both at the live and in that
extra footage we saw of you and Jed so
gracefully so flawlessly you said what
all of us as women wanted you to say and
you were such a champion for your own
heart and for what you deserve and what
I appreciated too Hannah was you weren't
very gracious about Jed's ex you said
you felt for this girl what would you
say to her
I know that it hurts too I've been in a
similar situation in my past before and
I think from this I hope that she's
learned a lot just like I have and knows
I hope she knows her Worth and what she
deserves and I hope that she can find
somebody that really truly makes her
happy one day too when you and Jed were
talking I mean we're all watching it and
we're not really believing what he's
saying hey it wasn't making sense he was
drunk when he said I love you were you
believing him in that moment or did you
feel like he was lying to you about some
stuff I don't know if he was lying I
think he was trying to justify why he
did the things that he did and I think
that's truly what he believes their
relationship was not exclusive what he
did he I think he thought that each
other's families yeah I I think he
really hadn't put together what that
would feel like for her for me and for
going how it would affect our future I
think he has realized that now let me
ask you about things with Tyler when and
where is this drink gonna happen is it
on the books like I said I just got off
a plane we saw each other after the show
and gave each other hugs and see you
later and we'll we'll figure out one's a
good time for both of us hang out well
how deep are your feelings for him right
now that's only been two months ago and
so my feelings just don't go away but
also we've both been hurt I hurt him I
was hurt through that and I was hurt
through the relay
that I had so I think it's really
important that if any any type of
relationships gonna happen for Tyler and
I that we hang out and just see where
we're at and you know that's that's
friends if it's more than I'm good with
that because I want to continue to be a
part of his life and I think he wants to
be a part of mine but at what capacity I
don't think we know you just yet but
excited to see him and catch up if it
ends up being just friends
would you support Tyler as the bachelor
I think it'd be a little hard to see him
as a bachelor because there still
feelings there but I would support him
in his happiness I think that is the
main thing it's figuring out what will
make both of us happy and if that's for
him to go on and to have the opportunity
to be the bachelor then I would support
him and finding his happiness just like
he supported me with dead people call
him the respectful king this is a tough
question but just part of you wish that
you just had pick Tyler originally I
could go back in and be like shoulda
coulda woulda with a lot of things but I
do know that I held back my feelings
with him for a really long time and in
that moment I felt everything but I I
think I was scared and thought it was a
little too late to be able to change my
mind and be able to be engaged but I do
know that those feelings for him were
real and true and I can't change it
because I learned a lot do you wish
you'd done no engagement I don't know if
I can say I wish I would have done
anything differently I think I was
excited yeah you you were in the moment
I got quick quick questions for you to
finish off here one fans love you
already cheering you on would you be the
Bachelorette again that is way too early
to even talk about that I am still
trying to process of what the heck
happened with me this time but I know
that I will always appreciate the
opportunity that I had to be the
bachelor to feel loved and to be able to
give that and I know that it can happen
here but as far as hey Hannah beasts
round two I don't know if anybody's
ready for that include
you could roar very quickly Dancing with
the Stars yes no maybe
I mean I I don't know but dance Hanna we
saw that I can you know move to rhythm
Demi lavato your new pal she's got a
crush on Mike could you set her up with
him I definitely have booked up for Demi
if she wants to be with Mike and I would
give her my blessing so I'm just really
glad to have somebody in my corner
that's so supportive that's been through
this type of public eye in a much larger
capacity than I had that it can really
just be there for me and just really
thankful for her well Demi's a great
singer watching Jed's singing back what
did you think what was that like some of
those moments were tough to watch
backhand in retrospect Chris Harrison
called a proposal cringe-worthy
[Music]
well I think it's it's hard because the
whole thing is tainted and yeah the
proposals cringe-worthy I think more so
because you're watching a girl think
that she's getting everything she wanted
and I am I didn't and yeah I'm not
really gonna comment on his singing
because he's passionate about that and
that's something that he can continue to
move forward with but Danny's a really
great singer you're right do you think
Jed can change yeah I definitely think
that this has been a huge learning
experience for him and I know that he's
sorry and the guy that I fell in love
with is in there and I think this has
really made him reflect on his life and
his choices and I do believe that he
will be a good man for somebody someday
[Music]